nancy pelosi i think is very important
because
she she's like a modern-day motivational
speaker when you put the camera on her
kai ki fire can you pull up the videos
please so the other day she's being
interviewed on jim cramer go to jim
cramer first
and and don't don't play idea but jim
cramer's interview on her
and uh in the middle of it he doesn't
even know how to catch himself and by
the time he goes that direction he
doesn't even know how to turn it back
around and go through it so watch what
happens here in an interview nancy
pelosi
did with jim cramer click on this
between you and i think secretary listen
to what he says what he calls it what
deal can we have a
crazy nancy i'm sorry
i have such reverence for the office i
would never use
that term but it is like you just didn't
but you just did
you know what i mean that's pretty bad
by the way to do that right i mean
pause it before it goes to the next one
that's pretty bad to do what's your
reaction when you see that here's mine
i didn't know wax figures could speak
that was um she looks like she's at the
wax museum
on fisherman's wharf in san francisco
here's the funny thing about kramer
that was that was planned i mean that
wasn't an accident he couldn't think so
i think so no no i think it was i think
it was i think he would i think it was a
bet i think it was a dare
i don't think that was i don't call her
crazy nancy when i think of nancy pelosi
where are you pulling this from where
you pulling this from this is your
facial recognition
though my opinion totally my opinion
abilities yeah all right it's by
watching him and the way he pulled it
back so quickly
so he goes he wait one more time let me
see that one more time sounded like a
good idea but he
regretted it as soon as he said it
secretary you agree with tom
what deal can we have a crazy nancy i'm
sorry
that was the president i i i have such
reverence for the office
i would never use that term but it is
like you just didn't
but you just laughed that was in his
teleprompter
okay adam thoughts okay i don't think he
planned that i mean he reversed course
so quickly
uh number one i don't i have the utmost
respect for jim crainer
jim not a fan of donald trump jim cramer
if you can tell anything about jim cram
no question he is not a fan he had a
hard time giving him credit
so is it personal with kramer i mean
they're both new yorkers i mean they're
on the same page but they're on the same
team so for him to do that
they are on the same camp now watch what
happens yesterday with george
stephanopoulos
ky if we go to that one right it's right
next to it watch this one here this
one's a very awkward
voting the day that we lost ruth bader
ginsburg but to be clear you're not
taking any arrows out of your quiver
you're not ruling anything out
[Music]
good morning sunday morning
the uh that we have a responsibility
we've taken over to protect it and the
constitution by the way go back
okay good morning sunday morning
it's like a cold yeah we have a
responsibility
we take it okay we gotta say full
disclosure here's the thing
that sound that's the aol sign obviously
that was a spoof
but that's exactly how she responded
responded to this
played one more time to see george's
reaction one more time
but to be clear you're not taking any
arrows out of your quiver you're not
ruling anything out
[Music]
good morning sunday morning look at this
way
that yeah we have okay
go ahead okay pat for being in the news
for 15 years doing
live television newscasts every day for
15 years let me tell you what happened
right there
stephanopoulos the question was so
stupid quills in your arrow in your
quilt what i mean are we archers
i mean what the hell was that yeah okay
so that was planned
he told her the exact question he was
going to ask verbatim
that's why she used the same phrase and
that's why he was so perplexed once he
started talking because she got off the
talking points
all right either she look i don't know
if there was some sort of problem with
her hearing him i don't know what the
pause was
but she is 80 years old she makes a
a compelling argument for my age limit
in congress every time we see her on
campus not term limit but age limits age
what's the age limit what's your age
limit something less than her that's
what
i'm i'm asking you that you're saying
you want it that's my official
stuff
but here's the other thing is um but
what's the age tom seriously um
i think once you get past 75
there's other things for you to be doing
in life i i really presidency
i mean be a amaretto emeritus you know
just
meredith yeah emeritus uh on an advisory
board or something
a consultant but not in the day-to-day
trenches 75 is your cutoff
you know it's it's around 75. all i can
tell you is she's too
old to be doing what she's doing and she
keeps
proving it to me see i don't i don't i
mean look you look at warren frickin
buffett dudes 90 years old
i think he's still a rock
yeah i don't think it's so much an age
limit thing i think it is a term limit
thing i'm sick of people just
year after year after year after year
whether they have cognitive cognitive
decline or not
just showing up and doing interviews am
i a fan of pelosi no am i a freaking fan
of mitch mcconnell
no okay so something's got to give i
mean the biggest thing here is let's get
all these older people whether it's
trump
biden mcconnell pelosi schumer let's get
them the
out of office and let's have millennials
start taking over in the coming years
that's my
that's what i'm voting for wait a second
i changed my mind keep the old people in
millennials are turning 40. okay
millennials are no longer uh 18 years
old okay
let's see the oldest millennial 40 years
old let me ask you a question gen x two
pat are you for my gen x or are you
hinting at you have an interest in
politics this is guys this is my big
announcement i wanted to come out here
you know adam wants to run this is the
playboy party
we're coming out we're gonna have ladies
and gentlemen
the white house you like getting laid
and making money come and join the
playboy party all right
except about the white house you're
gonna pull like a nice cave and park
some fun people
at the grotto you imagine there's like
it's like i got your motto
putting the party back into the
democratic party exactly right let's do
it wow
okay i would run as an independent
though i wouldn't but do you do you
think she's losing her mind
i think she's already lost it she's
already kind of you know
she's she's 80 years old uh she's lost
her mind you think i know i do not think
she's
lost her mind completely just like i
don't think biden has dementia
but he's clearly slipping she's clearly
slipping a little bit okay
here's the slippery slope just like i
don't think trump is all there
oh my gosh buddy listen let let me put
it to you this way you're going to
defend trump now
in this area i just called him out
earlier on tick tock for not getting the
deal done if you're such a deal maker
finish up the tick tock
i just i don't think he's all there okay
you can't say that about that guy you
can't say it about buffett you can't say
it about certain guys they're sharp
as hell that this has got nothing to do
with age i've met
55 year olds that are no longer sharp
and i'm at 85 year olds that are sharp
i'm telling you i've sat down with
people that are 85 year old businessman
and i'm like how the hell do you
remember what i said seven years ago to
you
an 85 year old right this has to do with
the individual
this has not to do with a specific age
this has to with the individual
there are certain people today should
not be driving there are certain people
today shouldn't be driving and they're
65. there's certain people that are 80
year olds are driving fine but there are
certain people that don't have a clue
how to drive
let's not call out our asian community
we're good friends with them let's keep
them and let's not call it our female
company
i think even america is a safer place
the fact that you haven't driven for
seven minutes
hey pat last night in that video i will
say uh
pat why don't we talk about uh are you
driving one time on my drive let's talk
about your driving experience
this weekend on live you're gonna call
me out i'm calling you out call me out
go let's go see what you're going to say
so pat isn't those bookshelves full of
your
driving tickets back yeah so the last
let tom say the last thing about this
we'll go through this driving
the final take about that video and the
one thing that stuck out is me is where
was uh stephanopoulos jumping in and
interrupting her and
like he did with the trump town hall
last week so that's why i say that
question with stage 100.